emily is with us in Greensboro North
Carolina welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Emily
hey thanks taking my call sure not going
to help and so my husband and I are
newlyweds you married for about four
months and and we are on baby step
number two but we're having a little bit
of marital conflict over it and I was
wondering if you can help us out okay so
I don't
I took FPU about a year and a half ago
the company that I was working for
offered it online for free my husband
has not gone through it but um
has been on board with everything that
I've been saying that we should do and
so we have the public deliver this we
have about five thousand dollars in
savings he does not feel comfortable
with the $1,000 emergency fund where I
would rather go ahead and you know fight
for thousand dollars of it into a check
um you know towards our student loan
debt how much how much debt do you have
not counting your mortgage um about
thirty five thousand and what is your
household income and about seventy two
okay and so if we throw four thousand at
the 35 we've got thirty one how long
would it take you to pay that off making
seventy two maybe this is why you're not
comfortable you don't have a plan you
guys have not talked this through this
is what's going on you're talking in
general vague concepts and you have not
ever laid it out and what you need to do
is lay it out because I'm I don't a
thousand dollars is not supposed to make
you comfortable it's actually supposed
to make you very uncomfortable so you
get up off your butt and get the dadgum
debt paid off as fast as possible that's
the concept and that's what he's missing
but he's also thinking we may be in debt
forever you know why because neither one
of you have ever done the math as to
when you're going to get out of debt and
the price you're going to pay to get
there yeah I thought I am I had an app
for it but he's I mean supposedly if we
do it with one our snowball method right
now we'll be out in five years
oh that's not making anything extra and
I know you don't go with a thousand
dollar emergency fund for five years and
it does not take 35 years to power
thirty-one thousand dollars making 71
thousand dollars a couple that was just
on paid off a hundred and forty-four
thousand in 30 months they make they
make a they make a hundred yeah you guys
are being wusses I mean you're going to
roll up your sleeves and punch this and
you should be done in a year really yeah
yeah but you have no life during that
year you remember that part yeah no no
vacations no but he's right if you're
thinking five years it'd be ludicrous to
try to have a thousand dollar emergency
fund for five years of course that makes
him uncomfortable because he's that
would be smart to be uncomfortable but
to be slightly uncomfortable a little
bit scared for a year while we're
busting it and we got our ears laid back
and we're not on vacation and we're not
seeing the inside of a restaurant let's
we're working there and any pizza that's
made at our house is homemade I mean we
are doing this thing only way we get
pizzas deliver something man I mean it's
you are doing it you're selling so much
stuff the kids think they're next that
gets you out of that in the year yeah
I'll put you on thousand dollars for a
year but not for five years this is why
you all are having a problem because
you've not worked this through and you
haven't seen that it's a reasonable
process if you are unreasonable in your
approach is that logical
now I understand I think that just need
to do you have I don't even know if you
have this nut do you have anything where
you can put those numbers in and see you
know if I make X amount payment every
month this is how soon I'll get out of
debt you know with interest rates and
all of that yeah you the interest rate
really doesn't matter much I mean it's
$31,000 that's $30,000 it's $2,500 a
month for a year if it's $2,000 a month
it's going to be 14 months it's just big
math take 31 and divide it by the months
and you because interest rates very
irrelevant at this stage because you're
not keeping interest rates only relevant
when you've got a five or a ten year or
longer window when you have a twelve
month window interest is doesn't enter
into it much it's a little bit of the
fact but I mean it doesn't you know it
may throw your numbers off slightly but
if you'll just do big numbers like
that big chunks but see what that does
is that maybe the challenges you all
look at your budget as a as a couple and
say what if we got to do to get that
intense right where we are on a written
budget we're on every dollar yeah but
you're not on intense now right not five
years five years is not intense no
nobody is if I anybody that says five
years for 31,000 intense doesn't enter
into the equation no now the top months
yeah fine you know 12 months 15 months
whatever yeah yeah that's true
but I mean you haven't cranked it back
yet but you don't have him on board
you can't crank it back like that unless
your spouse is on board people are not
going you've got a sacrifice but the
only reason he would be on board is if
he sees the same thing here's the thing
what will it feel like when we're out of
debt what will we be able to accomplish
with our family goals when we're out of
debt we will be able to do this we'll be
able to do that we'll be able to give
we'll be able to travel we'll be able to
change our family tree this is why we're
doing it now once we've both agreed that
it's very important because the why is
so big why we're getting out of debt is
so big once we've got the importance
underscored and highlighted then we come
back and go okay how hard can we bust it
how much can we sacrifice how deeply can
we cut into our life so that we get our
life back I don't want to do this for
long i'ma rip the band-aid off guy I
don't want to peel it off one hair at a
time it'll it'll kill you you know and
so I want to do it fast as I possibly
can live like no one else so later you
can live and give like no one else and
that's what the two of you have got to
get on the same page on then you start
talking about stuff like whether baby
step one is correct or not it is only
eight but it is only correct in in the
context of the level of intensity that
I'm talking about you see so in other
words I'm saying if you came to me and
you said five years to get out of that
and that's how long it's going to take
you and I and I and my husband feels
uncomfortable with having a thousand
dollars in the bank for the next five
years I would have to agree with him
right is what I'm saying but I don't but
that's not what we teach you to do
hold on I'll have Lorna send you a copy
of the book the Total Money Makeover and
what I would challenge you to do is the
two of you to go through that book
together you and him go through it
together and when you walk through it
together and you say okay this is how
everybody's doing this is how six
million people about that book four and
a half million people been through
Financial Peace University this is how
these people have done this and it's not
freaking theory people do you know go
online look at the debt free screams
listen to their stories and talk about
go to the YouTube channel and watch some
of those debt free screams you'll see
what people are doing and when you see
what other people are doing you're going
okay yeah we can do this because that
guy on YouTube he didn't look that smart
I think we're smarter in him I think we
can do this I mean you can do it you can
do it but you can't play with it into it
you can wander into that you can't
wander out it's going to take too long
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below